Sebastian says Oh Jim came really
prepared like he had so many [ __ ]
jokes he came really prepared and I had
the script and I had gotten a bunch of
other Rickles stuff from performances
tonight shows roasts and I was just
doing it like when they to keep it fresh
I would do the dialogue and then just do
other jokes that they probably hadn't
heard yet just to try to keep it fresh
yeah and one of the jokes they used was
one of the the ones I had it didn't
matter but I was so happy to see that's
huge I mean it made me happy that I had
done that because that wound up making
it in I guess they like the way it
worked or the the physical whatever it
was it's so great you come in with your
own material and that's what ends up in
the movie that was Rickles material of
quitting your Rickles Joe yeah you're
like this is this one I wanted I was
very happy about that so it made me feel
good that Sebastian had said that cuz I
was glad I came and really prepared I
love your Rickles cadence too you don't
do like a full-on impression like it's
not a bad Rickles impression you know
just it's your voice but you have a
Rickles cadence about it notice I
thought it turned out really great
thanks man yeah you can only do
something again there's nothing worse
he's such a hard guy to do perfectly
unless you because again everybody knows
what Rickles looks and sounds like and
those guys all know him so you just kind
of you do him as you would you feel like
you're doing him yeah but without doing
it over the top yeah you know he's
awesome yeah I was I was I couldn't
believe it but the rest of the movie
after that I can't wait to watch it
again yeah because you're so worried am
I gonna be in it am I not gonna be in it
am i gonna ruin it am I not gonna ruin
it I was in it oh my god I knew there
was no more and you're waiting like oh
my scene should be here is my scene
gonna be there I didn't know when it
would be right no idea when they start
showing the outside of the Copa I'm like
man yeah maybe and then I see Pesci and
De Niro talking I hear I know the
dialogue I'm like oh [ __ ] and then they
showed more of me than I thought they
would again it's not a long scene and I
know it's not critical when I saw my
scene I'm like yeah I get why I was not
called up because there's other guys
that were in it like the guy that worked
in the meat plant who had more dialogue
to me and I said to Sam he's as
important in the movie as I am but he's
more important so I knew where I stood
in the in the scheme of things but yeah
it was a total win it was a total
win-win and and again it's funny I was
talking to
again and just a typical comic he's like
we're in this thing for every what we
can't believe we're in this thing that's
what I was thinking like for you this is
one of those things that no matter what
happens in show business you're like no
matter what that exists now yep and it
can never be taken away it doesn't have
to lead to anything it could be the last
thing you ever do it could be the firt
it doesn't matter that exists in the
universe and you can never take it away
you're in the irishman one more Jim and
Sam catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM Adam